welcome back to the toast for a very
special Friday episode I'm sitting down
this is giving very watch weapons live
one on one it's me and it's Jax not the
Jacks that you're used to not Jax ashrae
it's Jax Taylor hey Jack hi Hi how are
you doing I'm so excited that you're
here
um it looks like New York is on fire
it's
you'll be here during one of the worst
weeks Canada is on fire and all the
smoke I can't even breathe it's crazy
outside right everybody's outside right
now taking pictures
they're so nuts like they're inhaling
smoke but they're just taking a picture
yeah they're just out there taking
pictures in the street right it's crazy
anyway how you doing I'm so happy to be
sitting down with you this is of course
not your first time on the toast but
this is arguably your most important
visit yet this is very much my most
important visit yet can you believe I
can't I've been waiting for this day
forever I have I have I knew there was
going to be a day where like oh man am I
ever going to be able to get on the
toast I'm just a big fan I don't know
how many male listeners you have I am I
hope I'm up on the top of your list of
favorites oh a hundred percent like you
and Brittany are the best Brittany
couldn't be here which is devastating
she's working right now you know she's
got her cup she launched today I saw and
I got the bathing suits they're so cute
you did okay I did I know yes I did a
lot of press and stuff for that right
now but that's okay because I'm really I
need to talk to you let's get into it
can you like
can you believe what has happened I know
you can't because you know yes because I
know these people a b I've never been
wrong on this show I've never been wrong
on the show people say yeah Jax you've
lied you've done this but it always
comes out being true so actually I've
never really lied on the show no that's
true and I feel like I have liked you on
the show for a long time and you had ups
and downs with the fans 100
um and since you've been off the show I
feel like it's actually been really good
for your your Q score it's been
everything right everything I needed it
I needed it it was one of those I had to
find the silver lining in it all but I
really really needed this like it just
you know we had a baby obviously the
world was kind of upside down with covet
and just kind of the world was changing
and you know we weren't quite sure if it
was gonna be if we were gonna come back
to TV or not but we know we talked about
it and my relationship is very strong
and you know Brittany and I are very
good and my family's very good so we're
definitely
um you know thinking about getting back
into it again yeah but I feel like you
guys are really thriving outside of
reality TV I hate to say it
thanks to the scan of all things it's
kind of bro I mean I'm going to bring
light to it obviously that's bringing
everybody kind of it's good for business
you know everybody's kind of talked
about that's not on the show anymore but
uh it is it's good for business yeah
you're the podcast now not good for
obviously for certain people but
um you know everyone's kind of doing
good from this I think yeah maybe him
it's also brought the show really back
into it's like when it's Heyday you and
your cable knit sweater Stussy slapping
Kristen like it's really brought the
show back to the right Geist a lot of
new listeners too like there's new
people kind of getting into it now
watching it and binging it and
everything and I'm just like it's so
cringy because like I have to watch
sometimes episodes to go back into my
podcast and talk about it and I'm like I
don't like to watch myself on TV I make
that known that I don't like to watch
myself but I have to drink like a case
of beer to watch myself are you getting
like a wave because there's all these
new people watching the show binging it
on peacock and they're just meeting you
for the first time and you've made your
fair share of mistakes on TV when you're
working out and now are people like
tweeting you like Jax I can't believe
you did that and it was like literally
2010. I know I know I literally like you
did this you this one that's what you do
in your well I mean I was in my early
30s you know well I wasn't that young
but you know I was just having fun on a
reality show I mean I didn't really take
it so seriously I didn't I didn't know I
mean things are obviously a little
different now I'm married and everything
in in uh and I feel like I'm in a good
place now so I feel like we are in a
good place to come back to TV yeah like
we're strong enough now we're probably
stronger than ever you know things are
going are really good and um yeah it's
it's I can't complain and people want
you back they do I'm surprised like the
amount of people and like the networks
and everybody's call contacting us are
you ready to come back do you want to
come back where do you guys stand
um how's the baby uh how's Brittany are
you guys it's every day it's like where
are we at where are we going what what
are we doing
um so yeah it's it's been great let me
ask you a few questions before we start
because I'm when you guys left
Vanderpump Rules cleared up were you
fired or did you leave we it was a both
of us kind of came together and mutually
left and we're not fired though um if I
think and people say were you fired well
if we were fired we wouldn't be on Watch
What Happens live right would it be you
know talking to Bravo right now we
wouldn't be doing all we wouldn't be I
wouldn't be in New York right now for
Bravo so if they hated us that much I
don't think this would be happening
right right and then in terms of your
actual like social status within the
group can you run me through who you and
Brittany are cool with and who you're
not cool with wow um well last night we
hung out with arya's new boyfriend are
they official boyfriend girlfriend I
mean I hope so I hung out with him last
night and I hung out with Stephen from
summer house remember Steven love and um
we had such a good time last night and
Sheena obviously in Brock uh we had a
really really good time I really like
this new guy a lot I mean we hit it off
instantly I came in I knew he was coming
I had a beer ready for him and we just
nice to meet you in yada yada but we
just had a good time but as far as
everybody else to hang out with Lala
Kristen uh Sheena
um Kristen Sheena
yeah who am I missing Tom well before
the Scandal what was your status with
the toms
um I always talk to Tom Schwartz he's
always been my best friend nothing's
ever changed with him I just have never
talked to Tom Sandoval ever again the
last time I saw him was on the day that
everybody saw on the show uh where he
went for labor it was a memorial day or
later I think it was Labor Day Labor Day
weekend barbecue at our friend's house
that's the last time were you there I
was there so in the show I was talking
to him when he got the text from Ariana
saying my dog passed or I'm sorry it was
his grandmother her grandmother it was
her grandmother her grandmother passed
away like and he's like oh man I gotta
get out of here like this and he's like
I can't find an Uber meanwhile this is a
huge home right and it's it's Memorial
weekend and he lives in a cul-de-sac so
Ubers were coming and going all day long
so you know saying that I can't find an
Uber is a little bit on this season when
they were saying Jason left is that you
or that's a different Jason because your
name technically is Jason right uh I
didn't hear him say that did it say that
oh they were saying like you could have
left with Jason oh Jason the drummer
sorry someone else yes so that's their
drummer that's the person he could have
left with yes because his he came with
his drummer and I think Raquel showed up
I don't know if that she's planned that
staggered that or whatever but she
showed up like five minutes later and
Jason was the drummer that's who he came
with and he could have left with her yes
right I'm sorry so walk me through
because when we all first found out
about the affair it seemed like it came
out of nowhere and then we're watching
Vanderpump Rules and we see like lala
kind of had a suspicion Katie everyone
was like a little bit it wasn't just
this total out of the blue people had
had suspicions because they were at the
Abbey and they were being weird tell me
your experience finding out either about
the affair or were you suspicious too
I've I've called it for day for years
this is like as far as the cheating goes
with it who it was with uh I was a
little shocked by Raquel you're not
shocked but I was kind of like okay I
thought it was a couple other people in
fact I I still believe in my head that
it's been a couple other people
um but no I wasn't when when the news
broke actually my friend texted me how I
found out it was my friend Janet's uh
husband texting me buddy Jason he goes
hey you were right all along I woke up
and I'm like what are you talking about
he's like you didn't haven't seen you
ever looked on social media I'm like no
and look at you know Tom's Channel
cheats you found out when the world
found out yeah yeah my buddy texted me
when I woke up and I was kind of like no
I'm not shocked nothing on this show
shocks me because I've called everything
on the show that's happened yeah and
you're fine by the way the little
surprise that you're gonna hear the show
I called that too yeah I'm shocked by it
your final season was really your last
sort of effort to make everybody see in
Sandoval what you saw like you said that
this was not a good person and he was
very manipulative and he's good with
words and he he's good at words and he
knows how to turn things around he likes
to say butt all the time and he deflects
and turns things around and always goes
back to Old stories you look crazy yeah
he can't just say you know what I effed
up screwed up I made a mistake I'm human
he has to go I screwed up but you did
this and you did this like just own what
you did yeah you're a 40 something year
old man you screwed up you made a
mistake own it it's a big mistake but
just own it my thing with Sandoval that
I find so confusing is like he's clearly
this insane narcissist he's you watching
the show especially in the last few
seasons he's never taking accountability
for anything he's throwing everyone
under the bus and now he's done this
like deeply morally unethical depraved
thing and I think okay listen cheating
is obviously very very bad and you know
every reality show I feel like has a
cheating scandal it's just the way he's
going about it is the scary part the
lack of empathy the selfishness the tone
deafness just now he's going on tour
changing the words of his songs and
making it about his phone falling out
like he's almost making fun of the
situation
he's laughing at and it's a little bit
like that's serial killer type [__] a
hundred percent did you say [__] yeah
sorry I mean that's that's scary it's
one thing if he was like man he was down
like I've been through this before I've
gone through this it's not on this level
but uh I was devastated I fought for for
a long time to get my now wife back on
the phone on the phone getting myself
help making sure everything was right
this is on a whole different level this
isn't just cheating this is like
something far beyond and it's like when
you watch them both on TV it's like they
have no sadness at all it's like they
grin it's like you just want to like a
Smacker yeah her too it's like I can I
have another problem with her too is
like in the beginning I thought she was
just an idiot like I thought she was
just completely dumb but it's not like a
victim of him now I'm like is she
calculated like she's almost like
yeah this is very calculated I can't
make up my mind I had Tom on my podcast
yesterday Schwartz and I'm like I can't
figure her out I'm like you're a lot
closer than than I am with her I mean is
she an idiot or is she just very
calculated and he's like you know I
don't know she's just she's a scary
human being but you've known Tom for so
long and you at one point we're very
close with Tom so like my question is is
what I've really been talking about his
name tattooed on my arms yeah I got Tom
and Tom we were best friends so I got
Tom Tom and I it's actually really cute
you should get rid of it but it's also
like a moment in time I know Bernie said
I shouldn't get rid of it because it was
a moment in time I know it's part of
History it is but my question is like
has Tom Sandoval always been this person
has the show escalated it to another
level was he always this like crazy
narcissist or is it something that
slowly happened over time he's just good
at what he does he plays this act and
he's like I do all these great things
for everybody sometimes not people who
do nice things aren't nice people no
they only do it so it's like a form of
currencies and then you throw it back in
your face exactly and that's what he is
very good at he will do that for
everybody but then throw it back in your
face and then use that like to like okay
I can get away with everything because
I've done so many nice things so I think
this has been going on for years and I
guess people are just blinded by it but
I wasn't I mean I clearly have called
him out many times and I got so much
backlash for it but I mean I guess I'm
grinning a little bit more now these
days because people are finally seeing
it you know it took them long enough but
I've seen all this for so long so that's
why nothing is like Jax are you
surprised did you see the reunion it's
like nothing no there's no this
surprising me I've called all this and
now in hindsight what are your thoughts
on Tom Sandoval paying for a portion of
the engagement between Raquel and James
it was so weird now I can't I can't
figure that one out no same do you think
they were literally like into each other
at that point
uh you wanted to make it special for her
I mean I can say it now yeah they were
it came out yesterday oh okay so yeah so
they were added at Mexico they were they
he and I'm surprised out of all the
people he lied to I'm surprised he lied
to Tom Schwartz his business partner
that was that would be the one person I
would probably confide in and be honest
with yet because you have a business
together he is your best friend you guys
literally I mean Tom I feel like
Schwartz and sometimes kind of maybe in
some way I think kind of his marriage
ended a little bit because of this I
mean a lot has gone down because of Tom
Sandoval and I feel like Schwartz is the
only one that's been in his quarter he's
on the ship and it's sinking and it's
burning and he won't get off he won't
get off and I talked to him yesterday
about it and I think he's finally
starting to you know what to realize
he's got a lot going on in his personal
life too he's got issues with his dad
his brother has cancer his other
brother's in rehab you know and Tom is
the sweetest guy ever he's constantly
shelling out money to his family so
money is going into his pocket going
right out windows out right out so when
you start a bar you know it's a very
expensive thing everything is not you
know just giving you you have to put a
lot of your own money and they put a lot
of their own money they tell Sandoval
borrowed from his mom he borrowed like
200 Grand from his mom her retirement
terrible you know just borrowing and
borrowing and borrowing to start a bar
and meanwhile Tom Schwartz's personal
life is falling apart yet Tom Sandoval
is going off on these band tours while
Schwartz is trying to start this bar
like this is his thing you know if this
fails he doesn't know what he's going to
do he needs help he needs support and he
finally cracked I don't know if he's
noticed that episode where he's like
you've been off doing all this band crap
we're trying to get a bar started
you know I I just I don't I don't want
to say I Told You So to Tom I don't but
I've kind of warned him about this so
many times I go first of all don't start
a business with your friend yeah you
never start a business with a friend you
don't especially a bar especially a bar
sure enough look what's happened now do
you place any blame on Sandoval for the
demise of Tom and Katie's marriage
um
you know what Tom Schwartz is a big boy
he makes his own decisions do I think it
weighed a little bit on it yes I do of
course but at the end of the day but at
the end of the day Tom's a big boy he
puts on his you know his pants by
himself so I I
I I feel like
it has a little bit to do with it about
trying to be nice about how I say this
but yeah I I yeah it has a little bit to
do with it of course of course I I'd be
an idiot if I said no and what are your
thoughts in General on Tom Schwartz's
role in this affair like him and his
weird relationship with Raquel I I think
he was thrown in the middle like
yesterday he was so sad on the thing
yesterday he's like you know I just kind
of Tom doesn't like to get involved in
too much stuff he doesn't like you're
really nervous the guy's constantly
popping anxiety pills because he has
anxiety because everything is going on
his life so you add all this on top of
it and he doesn't want to know all the
stuff that's going on he'd rather not
know but he does know so it's it's
driving him crazy he knew like some
portions of it you know I don't think
the timelines are matching up and I
think as you guys watched the episode
today yeah you'll see that he full on
live to his partner and his best friend
Tom Schwartz which I'm gonna I'm gonna
text Tom after this like did you watch
yesterday did you see because none of
them saw this none of them knew because
you'll see on the episode Raquel comes
back when the episode ends and all of a
sudden it says six weeks later she pops
on yeah and then Raquel goes on and says
I've been lying to everybody this is
what's going on we've been hooking up
way longer than everybody said Tom has
been telling me what to say right and we
all knew Tomball was coaching her that's
why he blew up on her can we have five
minutes why do you need five minutes
yeah that was cool why do you need the
five minutes without the cameras what
can you say that you can't say in front
of the cameras you signed up for the
show you need to talk about your
relationship and that's one thing that
bothered me about him on the show is he
never talked about his relationship we
all were open books signed on the dotted
line yeah we have a pretty cool life and
it's very fun but you got to pay for it
you can't have your cake and eat it too
it's not how it works true you were like
you went through bad stuff that's just
like embarrassing stuff yes yeah
horrific I got it from everybody but
that's part of the gig you don't want to
do it then don't do it but you can't
have your cake and eat it too like I
just use can't and yeah talk about
something kind of serious the band
how serious who what when where why how
like it's a nine person band that he
pays everyone basically to hang out with
on venmo yeah on venmo right I'm sure
his accountant is like pulling his hair
out
I don't know if he has an account he's
got leans up the ass on his house I want
to get into the finances too but really
just the band my first question is like
why Tom Sandoval and like this is not me
being mean this is just me being like a
human being can I say one thing yeah
before I forget it Tom Sandoval two days
ago this is how tone deaf and selfish
this person is he was having his band
was performing in Louisville he texted
Brittany two days ago from today
hey if you have any friends in
Louisville love to see you coming let's
come come to my band I'll get you free
passes I looked at the phone I go is he
by the way nobody knows this yet we
haven't talked about this are you
[__] serious this is two days ago
from today did she respond and I said I
I go I look at the phone and I give the
phone back to Brittany and I went on my
phone I'm going to ever [__] text my
wife again how dare you I go how selfish
and tone deaf are you you do realize
Britney is friends with all these girls
right what do you think she's gonna do
sure Tom
um hold on let me write down let me call
him up they'll be right there
okay I'm sorry go back to your story but
this just happened and I know that's
crazy I know but anyway go back to the
band and that's what a true narcissist
does like doesn't realize the gravity of
even sending a text like that it's like
not well it's like like a serial killer
who kills their family and then goes out
to the bar and just yeah yeah yeah I
mean like right but the band okay and
this is just my opinion like Tom
Sandoval is not a talented singer
correct so why would he start a band I
think it's kind of one of his lifelong
dreams ever since I've known him I've
known Tom for 20 plus years we've lived
together since we were 19 years old we
start off in Miami together he wants to
be a rock star that's just who he is
that's just who he wants to be in great
you should have dreams and goals and
whatever
um but keep it in your living room it's
really bad it's bad you know what I
would give it to him if he was good and
be like yeah he's a shitty person but
the guy can sing
or whatever yeah but he can't no it's so
bad and out of the nine people that are
in the band not one person is saying
does anybody else want to give this a
try I mean they're all getting paid like
that trumpet player you want to give us
they're getting paid a thousand dollars
a day I would shut up too like I don't
even know they're getting paid I think
is that what it is that's what he was
saying why he's so stressed earlier in
the season he was like literally at this
recording studio venmoing all the people
who had to spend with him practicing and
like getting ready for tour so the
travel yeah the The Outfits the
nine-person band Hotel the hotels
I mean you're not Metallica dude you're
not you're not Journey okay like who's
paying these people and now I'm getting
late they're doing free concerts so
who's paying for this okay so that's
what I want to talk to you about because
you actually have extensive knowledge of
what
what someone in Tom Sandoval's position
is making from the show right you were
on the show for a very long time and I'm
sure towards the end you were making a
lot per episode right I won't make you
say but I am curious
um so you know how much money he
probably has you know he right but he
spends a lot so that's that's between
the house oh the house and the bar and
the car the brand new Mercedes SUV right
the overspends how much trouble is he in
he's in a lot of trouble yeah and
financially but thank God I mean this is
one of the pluses about I guess this is
what I don't know about I know they're
not married but in California there's a
common law situation community property
right and I know I don't know if the
house is in both of their names I
believe it is is it in both their names
I'm not sure I know they have a lawyer a
real estate lawyer taking care of this
it's that bad where they have to get a
lawyer involved because he won't leave
the house
yeah which is weird to me just
disgusting guy yelled at me when this
happened to me he's like get out of your
house what are you still doing there
you're still living in yours oh my God I
forgot about that everything he's yelled
at me about every single thing he's
yelled at me about her or made me feel
like [__] about he has done you're so
right he is done that's so crazy
foreign
is brought to you by State Farm the
State Farm personal price plan helps you
create a plan that gives you options so
you get an affordable price and it comes
with a lot of benefits like the coverage
you want a policy that helps cover
what's important to you and most
importantly an affordable price just for
you because insurance is personal some
might say more personal than comedy some
might say more personal than food you
know take Jackson I have you seen two
girls more similar and even we have such
Niche different insurance needs Jackie's
a homeowner a car owner a Tesla owner
I'm a renter we have different needs
okay
so that's what's so great about
personalization it means you have the
power to choose what you want to include
in your plan and what you want to leave
out it just feels better that way and
insurance should work like that that's
what the State Farm personal price plan
is all about you can choose to include
options like bundling your home and auto
policies that means you'll get the
coverage you want at an affordable price
just for you in the end you have a
policy that gives you what you want
doesn't that feel better State Farm is a
brand we can trust you gotta get covered
you gotta go to State Farm like a good
neighbor
like a good neighbor State Farm is there
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan the prices vary by state option
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary again that's the
State Farm personal price plan and in
order to get that you can call or go to
statefarm.com today to create that
personal price plan today's episode is
also brought to you by game time buying
tickets to your favorite events should
not be stressful but these days it
really is game time is the fast and easy
way to buy tickets for all the sports
music comedy and theater near you with
killer deals on last minute tickets and
their best price guarantee you can stop
stressing over the tickets and start
getting hyped for the fun you're gonna
have game time is the place for last
minute ticket deals I'm constantly going
to events I told you guys this is like
my summer of concerts I'm actually going
to one this week like game time is so
great just I always have the app
downloaded on my phone when I'm walking
around I live in New York there's so
many fabulous things happening every
night from Sports to theater to music
that having the app on my phone is so
great they really have amazing seats
amazing deals
you get exclusive Flash Deals on tickets
for football baseball basketball
concerts comedy theater and more the
game time guarantee means you'll always
get the best price and if you find
tickets in the same section and row for
Less game time will credit you 110 of
the difference it's the fastest growing
ticket app in the country for a reasons
you get images of your seats before you
buy so you know exactly what to expect
when you arrive you can buy tickets in a
matter of seconds two Taps and you're
all set tickets are then sent directly
to your phone so you never have to dig
through your email it's Perfection
they've got you covered on all bases
from start to finish you're going to get
great seats you're going to get a great
deal and you're going to have a great
time Say Yes To Life snag the tickets
without the stress with Game Time
download the game time app create an
account and use code toast for 20 off
your first purchase terms apply again
create an account and redeem code toast
for 20 off download game time today last
minute tickets lowest price guaranteed
I know I think Ariana's going to be okay
I think she's but she's also raking it
in right now she's doing the
Bloomingdale's she's has these
commercials for Bic she's a star I heard
she's going on Dancing With the Stars
like she's gonna be fine oh yeah she's
yeah and I hate to use the word thriving
because everybody uses that word yeah
she really is it's a definition and I
tell you what her and eyes relationship
has never been an amazing relationship
but ever since this happened ever since
the uh the last day of the reunion I met
her at a bar they when they got cut we
all met at the bar and she just came up
to me I didn't even say anything just
give me a big hug I feel like she's got
so much weight lifted up she is a
different human being she was so angry
all the time she was depressed all the
time she never came out like I don't
know what it was from I mean well now I
do she was living with a monster she was
living with a monster and you see her
now and yes she's doing all these great
things but I know her better than that
as a person she just seems like a normal
girl again later just lighter just like
she's laughing no Ariana never and I
laugh together I know and she was just
like you guys are getting closer
literally the enemy of my enemy is my
friend right and it's just like I knew
she was there I knew she I knew it was
there I never understood why she was
always so negative and I didn't like it
I always had to walk on eggshells
because I was like ah she doesn't like
me she doesn't like me why what did I do
now is it because I'm just too much of a
guy's guy she doesn't like that but now
she's just like
I don't know she's just like a
completely different person I talked to
her brother every day I'm really good
friends with Jeremy and I'm like your
sister's just so like an awesome now
he's like I know he's got rid of that
deadbeat dead weight yeah literally I
mean as awful as this is I'm happy for
her I'm happy for her so I definitely
needed this as mentally she needed this
yeah that's kind of what I was gonna say
like it's a terrible thing that happened
but I think a lot of good has come out
of it one for Ariane I think you're 100
right you can tell on social media
there's just like a like an air to her
it's much lighter but also it's really
it's brought the show back to like the
Forefront of the culture people are
obsessed with it you know now Kristen
and you and Brittany and stassi like
people who weren't on the show are I
think a lot of people are it's creating
like a demand for you guys to be back on
Bravo everyone's podcasts are killing it
like it's it's really weirdly been good
for everyone except for Tom and Raquel
obviously yeah
um I just had this I had this
conversation with Sheena Brock last
night I'm like where is Raquel at the
current moment like where oh and another
thing
I asked Tom yesterday on my podcast are
Raquel and Tom dating because if they're
not together this was all for what
and he's like I don't think so I don't
think so that again I'm like so this was
just all for for nothing for nothing
just to like just take a big dump on
everything and leave I mean at least be
together the only way this would even
remotely be half okay was that if they
lived happily ever after I had a million
kids and we're in love for the rest of
time
which is not going to happen
like you know Tom is just too like he
couldn't control Ariana anymore she's
had enough she got older we found Raquel
he can control her she's very easily
manipulated and you can just pretty much
tell her whatever and she'll do it but I
don't know as of today I don't know
where she is she claims that she's
getting help but is she really is she in
a Marriott Hotel yeah I don't I don't
know I imagine she is getting help
because you know aside from what's
actually going on you know having the
weight of the world and every you're
she's a villain not on a reality show
she's a villain of America like how do
you bounce back from that I don't know I
think her best chance would to really
paint herself as a victim of time she's
an incredibly vulnerable young woman
she's very impressionable he's a much
older man who's a more principal
character on the show and she wanted
more it is like an imbalance of power
and I think that if she structured it
it's like her just totally being
influenced and swept away and how she
was a victim in all this too it's a
stretch but it's
I don't know he can't come back from
this
I I don't know where they go from here
because I know on the show none of them
wants to none of them are going to film
that was my next question as a show
right if everybody says we're not
filming with Brittany you know for
example what does that mean does that
mean Britney can't be on the show I
don't know I don't never ever had a
situation like this where literally
people will walk off set if they have to
film with her so I feel like they're
is there a world where they have a show
and then have his own thing going on or
I mean I don't know I the only person I
can see actually filming with him is Tom
Schwartz because they have a business
together and he'll probably get suckered
into it
um you know I
I was asked if I would film with them
and I I was like I you know I couldn't
do that oh my God I would absolutely
love for you you know how many people
are saying I'd love for you to sit in a
room with Tom Schwartz or Tom Sandoval
right now and have a talk how Vindicated
do you feel I feel a little bit I mean
just because I've been like saying this
for so long not like it's not like an
aha but I've been just saying this
because I've kind of like am I taking
crazy pills right
crazy pills for so long and I like I
said I'm normally I'm 99.9 right on the
show as far as what were you talking
about what were you wrong about I don't
know let me know if you find something I
was wrong about because I I haven't yet
to find anything that I've been wrong
about on the show so we know about Miami
girl we know about Raquel he finally
came clean with that which was Justice
for Kristen Dodie Ten Years Later yeah
yeah Justice for Kristen who what else
what's up with the Billy Lee Okay so
I my what I think I think they have
hooked up yeah I think so because they
were also recently just spotted together
they are she's coming out of his house
in the morning and she's also looking
for the Limelight yeah she wants a
little bit of you have to understand
that yeah yeah and um yeah but I mean
she's leaving the house really she's
walking Ariana's dog so disrespectful so
I don't know if if she's allowing this
or if he's just doing this just to be
like I don't give a [__] um
you know there's some so many things are
creeping in my head when he was talking
about the being in love he's like I get
her lattes every morning it used to be
like the little stuff I changed the
batteries in the remote he bought me
paper towels like just stuff like that
like dude do you know what love you you
are an idiot you are just you don't have
no idea what love is well you're close I
mean you do here yourself he loves
himself a lot more than anything a lot
he loves a mirror he does love a good
mirror you're close to Schwartz and I'm
really curious what the actual impact on
the bar has been for this whole thing I
know in the beginning people were like
boycotting in people like went and
vandalized the bathrooms but now it
really is like the center of this
worldwide Scandal and I have to think
like maybe it's good for business well
what's going on I think Tom from when I
asked him yesterday he says it has ups
and downs okay it's going through it's
it's Peaks and valleys but you have to
understand when you're saying all this
to Tom Sandoval you're not he doesn't
see any of this no you're hurting the
employees you're hurting the cooks
you're hurting the managers people have
the job that's their job and I you have
to as a business owner I understand that
I get that because when you're
vandalizing and you're boycotting it
yeah you you're
you know we get it you're upset at the
at the restaurant but you're hurting a
lot of people that are putting their
hard work into it um I was there I've
been there three or four times and last
time I was there wasn't that busy uh but
I just think maybe I was there on an off
night I don't know it was 10 o'clock on
a Thursday but that's not an off night I
that you know uh it wasn't really but
you know I for Tom Schwartz's sake I
hope it bounces back rumor again this is
just a rumor I heard that they are
trying to buy Tom Schwartz or Tom
Sandoval out the managers do not like
him the owners do not like him the
employees do not like him nobody wants
to work for him they're all only there
because of Tom Schwartz of course and
obviously Tom Schwartz is like please
please you know and he's trying to make
it work he's trying to make money yeah
and in fact they offered me if I was
interested in taking over could you
imagine well okay I'm so glad you
brought that up because I have two
things to say one just really quick what
do you think of the name shorts and
Sandy's I don't think you should ever
use people's names in bars it's
literally the worst name two
I remember when Jackie and I were
watching Lisa at someone's engagement
party basically pulled the toms over I
think it was actually your engagement
party which was even more [__] rude
pull the two Toms over and be like what
do you say we all go into business
together and Jackie and I remember we
were recapping we were like well that's
weird like yeah they have the same name
right but it's obviously about the show
Tom Schwartz has never worked at any of
the restaurants except the one time he
got behind the bar and had a panic
attack and
he's actually he wasn't really like a
main character at first it was almost at
last right and we were like well this
just feels like a slap in the face to
Jax like if this bar is going to be
representative of this show and this
franchise and the two guys the two guys
include Jax and I think simply your name
not being Tom is what put you out of the
running which is so dumb
um does it bother you did it bother you
and does it now that they didn't at
least that didn't include you I think at
the time with the TomTom thing I was a
little like yeah I mean like what am I
chopped liver what have I done no no
I managed your bar I waited at your bar
I've done everything at your bar I've
kind of been a good employee I've I've
kind of she's the only one that she
would come to me when she had issues on
housewives like how do you deal with
this when I was going through hell on
Seasons like well pretty much the whole
time uh she would pull me aside like how
do you deal with this we would have
one-on-one talks where Lisa would break
down to me and be like how do you get
through this the women are being like
this we would have one-on-one talks all
the time so yeah I was a little offended
by it but now looking back I wouldn't
owning a bar is like the hardest it's
the hardest thing to do especially if
you're married yeah it's like your
marriage will never last a a first a
band or a bar nope no no marriage will
last that so you would not go into
business or you would not saying that
but how funny would it be if I did
Sports and jackses or Jackson James see
episode one James
yeah what if we had our own what is
something like that you know him and I
are throwing a party on the 13th in L.A
okay wait
what is your current relationship status
with James Kennedy love them I think
he's hilarious I think he's hilarious
this season do you think he's the number
one guy in this group this season oh
yeah 100 the best yeah yeah I talk to
him all the time now and I think he's
great and he's just he's just he's funny
he's funny he says a lot of funny things
and he says [__] yeah he does like
normal normal people couldn't get away
with some of the stuff he says they'd be
like dude what are you saying but it
just with he says it it's just you're
just gonna have to laugh I agree I think
it's the accent or something because he
has had some like such [__] up [__]
but like there's something so endearing
about it right I know it's so weird I
like it I do I'm so glad that you two
are friends I think that's hilarious so
we were kind of just I was telling him
about I'm like listen I was offered I
don't know if it was a strong offer or
not I was at the bar late at night and
one of the managers or owners manager
slash owner of shorts and Sandy's like
Hey we're we want to get you know rid of
Tom Sandoval we want to find another buy
would you be interested and I just I've
been drinking and I was like oh I don't
know I don't think so I don't think
whatever I couldn't do that to Tom
Schwartz either I just don't it's just a
lot of work and a lot of pressure at bar
you know what I'm saying and we're
married to that I have a child and I'm
yeah I love my marriage right now and I
just I think owning a bar I guess if I
was involved with a bar where I didn't
have to be too involved I would do that
yeah like after something where I can
just like tap in and tap out but you
know Schwartz is there seven days a week
he's there every day and Sandoval is
never there he's never there I'm glad
you brought up Lisa because I'm curious
what your thoughts are on Lisa in terms
of like what first of all what's your
relationship with her
um I saw her at Tom Tom about two months
ago she's like hey how are you this and
and I don't know I just think she's
I don't want to say too many negative
things about Lisa I just I
I just I don't know I like the way Lala
gave it to her on the show Lala's
finally kind of stepping up everybody
seems to be afraid of her for what we
own a restaurant you're a woman who owns
restaurants in West Hollywood so for for
a while she was this authoritative
figure she was your boss and now she's
not nobody works at the restaurant
really anymore you have to understand
too people are like you should be so
grateful grateful for Lisa for getting
us the show we have to keep it going
she's not a like people say well she
owns the show she doesn't own the show
she is a producer yeah okay so it's
really upsetting a bunch of people like
oh my gosh you should be so grateful she
could let you go no that's not how it
works she got us the audition or she got
us the you know the the tease for the
show the sizzle reel whatever she got us
in the door we have to make it work you
guys ran with it her showing up once
every six episodes to hand out fake
paychecks yeah come on and then and then
watching the
um the reunion her chiming in she's not
even there these are adults when we were
younger we were 20 years old it made a
little more sense because she was kind
of a mother figure and she was the boss
none of us work at the restaurant right
none of us have worked at the restaurant
for a very very long time right people
say well we'll drink no wait none of us
have for a very long time it's a
television show what does the future
look like for her role that's a great
question very misplaced now and you're
right never this is a paycheck never
would anybody snap at her at a reunion
in the past like nobody and James was
giving it back to her Lala was giving
back to her yeah because she was
sticking up for Tom Sandoval do I think
she has to be neutral yes and no it is
her business partner so she has to be
like she has to see both sides she can't
just be everybody against Tom Sandoval I
get that I get she was trying to kind of
have
it made the conversation feel better
because everybody was just every time he
would speak everybody would scream and
it's like well I actually want to hear
what this insane person has to say so
her actually kind of being a referee I
didn't mind yeah I didn't think she was
really taking aside I thought she was
just like let him bury himself like let
him speak but I don't really know what
her Point what's the point of Lisa on
the show anymore just to be there sit
next to Andy I think she's a prop at
this point yeah and I don't mean that in
a negative way but let's be honest it
wouldn't change the difference if she
wasn't there she's not bringing anything
to the show anymore it's not it was in
the beginning yes she was very involved
but now like I said we're all a lot
older none of us have been at the
restaurant anymore
um yes this is her show she brought the
show but I really don't see a reason for
her to be at the reunion I really don't
I mean just to sit next to Andy and and
you want a piece of gum I don't I mean I
I don't really know do they just work
back and forth how's your restaurant
doing like I don't really know if she
really needs to be there yeah this has
just been the craziest like when I put
on my Instagram that you were coming on
the show we got so many questions for
you so I hope you'll answer some of our
fan questions okay they're not crazy
um the number one question was like
returning to Vanderpump
um I I say we have been talking
um we're trying to figure out what makes
sense for my family
um obviously we've we've been off for a
couple years so we want it to make sense
for us uh we are uh absolutely uh you
know excited about the thought of going
back but you know we have to weigh it
out and see if it makes sense for us so
we are definitely open to it right now
uh but we'll see what happens yeah but
it's been really good for you not to be
it has been really good for me not to be
but you know I also miss it a little bit
well that was actually but the thing is
too you have to understand nothing's
changed since we have the show when
they're filming everybody ends up back
at my house my house is the center uh is
the middle of it they all come back to
my house and they all vent and we all
hang out at my house nothing has changed
if anything the show's gotten less real
because now you're bringing in people
that aren't actually friends yeah you
know well that was actually my first
question that I forgot to ask you is
like you know this is a show that really
was built on the backs of a lot of
people you being one of them like you
had many embarrassing moments you were
very honest you talked about stuff with
your family like you lost your dad while
you were on the show like you were so
you committed to making the show good
and you leave and now is like this
Scandal that's taken over the entire
world is there any part of you that has
fomo or like a little bit of resentment
you're like well this is like a show
that like even you said at the end you
were like I started this show when you
said that to Lisa like is there a part
of you that has fomo from like this big
scandal
I got to be honest with you and and yeah
maybe last season but I don't know if I
want to be part of this panel right now
it said those girls were out for blood
yeah they're out for blood and I'm not
the wittiest person in the world I'm
kind of just a kind of a deer in
headlights I feel like I kind of like a
little bit of a Tom Schwartz in that
thing where I kind of just be like
please don't come to me please don't ask
me a question please don't ask me a
question yeah because they're so
calculated these girls were ready for
this and so I think I'm I'm doing
obviously we're doing okay everything's
fun right now and in the way this is
playing out because now I get to be I
get to like the peacock show I did I get
to watch it and give my opinion without
getting any that was actually one of the
questions we got for you
did that re-watch thing Brittany did and
but we only got like they only bought
three episodes I don't know if it was in
their budget I don't know if this is a
trial thing I'm always wondering why did
we only do those three episodes and not
the three at the end would have been a
lot more fun I know they were trying to
do more I don't know if it was a time
thing or a budget thing but uh no they
all loved it you know they were trying
to get more I don't know what the what
the deal was but we were definitely open
to do more we loved it we had so much
fun literally just go walk downstairs
sit on our couch watch the show and I
get to give my opinion without getting
any feedback it was like awesome I could
say whatever I want and No One's Gonna
yell at me back yeah it was amazing um
okay another question I have for you is
Kristin Doty has been doing a couple
podcasts and it seems like she's really
cool with everyone except for James and
she kind of alludes to this like thing
about James that's going to come out
like he has skeletons in his closet do
you have any idea what that is
I don't think so I mean I you know
Christian's a scary person to piss off
and she really is because she's kind of
like a MacGyver and she will dive deep
Miami girl you know Miami girl I'm
friends with all of her boyfriends and
her and I still bump heads because she's
kind of like you can't hang out with my
ex-boyfriends I'm like then I can't hang
out with anybody in L.A because you've
dated literally everybody in L.A I know
all your all your five boyfriends except
for Tom Sandoval I'm friends with all of
them I'm not I'm a 43 year old man if
I'm friends with a guy I'm not gonna be
like well I can't talk to you anymore
because you're not dating that girl I'm
not doing that I agree and we're not
Kristen by the way we're not sitting
around talking about you like her
ex-boyfriend Alex she hates the fact
that I'm really good friends with him
he's one of my best friends did you meet
him through Kristen and I no I met him
before Christmas okay through Tom
Schwartz and she started dating him now
she's like you can't hang out with him
you can't come anymore like and then she
calls she calls me like she was on with
her new boyfriend she was driving to
Colorado with her new boyfriend Luke and
she's calling me why are you hanging out
with Alex like I'm trying to think like
poor Luke is in his car like why are you
so mad that I am hanging out with your
ex-boyfriend who's moved on John who has
a new girlfriend we have a great
relationship and Kristen we don't talk
about you yeah you are not the topic of
conversation yeah I you know I don't go
around because like why you hang out
with my ex-girlfriend move on so you
don't know what this alleged you know
skeleton I don't know what this is I
don't know if Kristen's just doing her
homework right now right she's digging
deep you know what I'm saying if she's
maybe going through the archives I don't
know what she's doing I don't know what
she has planned but I mean I don't know
what it could possibly be yeah
today's episode is brought to you by
vegamore we are always trying to do
right by our bodies so when it comes to
hair and scalp Health finding a product
that really works and is made with clean
ingredients always seems like a
trade-off but with vagamore we get
products that are made with clean
ingredients and give us visibly healthy
hair and scalp we found vegamore a while
ago because Jackie's been on her clean
health kick and I'm kind of in this
regrowth phase of my hair and Jackie
really recommended their grow shampoo
and their serum and I've been using it
now for a few weeks vagamore is a
fabulous brand so many of you guys
recommended it for Jackie while she was
pregnant for me while I was going
through like my hair issues and I really
want to thank you guys with vegamore we
have visibly thicker fuller shinier
longer hair without all the harsh
ingredients all of vegamore's products
are 100 cruelty free they are never
formulated with potentially harmful
chemicals like parabens or hormones
what's even better is vagamore's value
kits like the grow Essentials kit that's
what we use that's where you get to try
more than one amazing product at Great
savings when you sign up for monthly
subscriptions you save more and you
never run low on the products that you
need to take care of your hair because
with these products consistency is key
I'm like always remembering before I go
to bed do my serum do my routine it's so
important to be consistent
we use the vagamore grow Gro kit it's
the hair serum we use that daily and
then the shampoo and conditioner are
fabulous too give yourself the hair you
never thought you could have with
vegamore for a limited time the toast
listeners can get 20 off their first
order by going to vegamore.com toast and
using Code toast at checkout that's
v-e-g-a-m-o-u-r.com slash toast code
toast to save 20 off your first order
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by one skin if you've ever thought
to yourself what if we could reverse the
root cause of Aging then listen closely
our new sponsor oneskin puts science and
research first founded by a team of four
female PhD level longevity scientists
with over 15 years of experience one
skin set out to not just decrease the
visible signs of skin aging but to
really treat the root cause of skin
aging so their essential face
moisturizer their topical eye
supplements you want to firm up your
skin and what I love is their topical
body supplement I am so conscious of my
neck and decolletage like wrinkles and
sagging that I loved this body
treatment because I thought it was so
smart and that's like one of my biggest
concerns
um it's going to moisturize your skin
it's going to make it look great but
it's also going to help it function like
younger and healthier skin all their
products are formulated with oso1
peptide as the primary active ingredient
so it supports the Skin's ability to
resist the effects of intrinsic and
extrinsic aging factors their flag
Flagship product the os01 face is
clinically proven to strengthen the Skin
Barrier and improve key skin Health
markers meaning signs of aging are
significantly diminished our listeners
can get 15 off one skin for a limited
time with code toast when they go to
oneskin.co so it's the world's first
skin longevity company they address skin
Health at the molecular level targeting
the root cause of Aging so skin will
behave feel and appear younger it's time
to get started with your new face eye
and body routine at a discounted rate
today get 15 off with code toast at
oneskin.co that's 15 off at oneskin.co
with code toast we only have one body
one skin and only you can choose to make
it better age healthy with one skin
we got so many questions about your
marriage and just your family and you
know following on social media really
appears like you guys are in such a good
place
um what do you attribute that to
maybe just the break of the show had a
lot to do with it yeah it was doing good
um you know I
I think because Britney's never been
around you know without without the show
you know so I think that helped a little
bit
um we're just we're best friends you
know do we argue a lot absolutely
because we live together we work
together we play together sleep together
and we do everything together is a
normal it's a normal thing we bicker all
the time but within five minutes we're
best friends again like we don't let it
bother us we don't go to bed angry we're
going to bicker it's what it is but
we're just best friends we like
everything the same we like just to sit
around and watch movies together we love
playing with our son everything we like
is the same except for music other than
that we pretty much like everything what
kind of music I like the older stuff she
likes everything new country Yeah
country yeah you know she's a Kentucky
girl yeah yeah I don't mind the country
but she likes all the rap every every
person that's named with a little she
likes them I don't understand that I'm a
journey you know
Journey Hall and Oates you know Dave
Matthews Band and so you just it's a
smile that's I'm a little bit old you
gotta remember I'm 10 years older than
her so oh right you know she likes all
the new stuff and I just I can't handle
with any of that
um tell me the last besides of the text
message that you just told us about the
last time you spoke to Sandoval was at
the Holiday party was at that Memorial
Day party oh right we ran into them and
you guys were like not on speaking terms
no I mean we we weren't mad at each
other I ran in and of course as soon as
I say hey hi how are you doing he
doesn't ask anything about my son never
met my son yeah Tom goes right into it
well I'm in the Band and this like I
didn't say hey man how you doing how's
your kid doing how's your family that's
what I do when you meet somebody that
you haven't seen what is the first
things you say how's your mom and Dad
how's your how's your husband how's your
wife how's Health everything okay how's
life then you can get into that he's
like not even that I haven't seen the
guy in two years yeah my band is doing
this oh yeah I had a kid right you know
you've never met Cruz no
that's so crazy no it's just like I
don't care but it's just like
you just not like grow up man he's not
like a real person backwards in life you
have this Peter Pan syndrome where you
just don't want to grow up are there
times in the last you know you said 20
years of your friendship with Tom
Sandoval were you covered for him
cheating
no I think I outed him on everything
yeah that's so you I I think I did
autoimone every time I think once it
came out no because he cheated on every
every girlfriend he's had yeah so yeah
no you weren't out here I was I I mean
he cheated on Kristen well with me but
uh yeah so and he yeah yeah no I've
always added him do you regret not going
to stasi's wedding
yes I wish I could have gone and I it
sucks that it's
still at this point I think it's
hopefully going to get better I hope
that we can become friends but it was
just such a it wasn't in the cards like
everything was going wrong yeah we
didn't get Cruz's passport so that's the
law I think you were planning on going
and then things happened we were going
to plan on going and then things were
happening and then you know it was right
in the middle of covid and I heard
people were getting stuck in Italy and
like you couldn't get back you know and
I'm like I can't afford to be stuck
there I have a mortgage I have money to
pay what if I get stuck over there not
only that Cruz's passport didn't come so
I was like you know what how about I
stay with the baby you go with your mom
that way somebody from our family is
representing the wedding then her mom
her best friend's husband died so it was
just kind of like I feel like she's not
in our cards it wasn't in our cards to
go and stassi was what upset that you
just didn't give enough notice yeah she
I didn't give enough notice but we felt
bad so I paid I gave her 500 you know to
cover the food and whatever because I
understand it's it's a wedding
announcement you know um I think she
sent it back though but I I just it
sucks it sucks that we have to be at
this point because of a wedding we were
at our first one you know and and
Brittany was loaned her shoe and
everything it's not it wasn't a
malicious thing right you know if it
just it couldn't work out and I feel bad
I wish tomorrow that we could be friends
like yeah I feel awful I said I'm sorry
a million times I don't know what else
to do both you and Brittany are not
speaking to her no no we haven't no
since the wedding debacle oh that's sad
yeah I know and I I I'm hoping one of
these days we cross paths I actually we
did no no that's not true because aren't
crews in Hartford similar ages yes
that's not true we did run into them
they did talk at Lala's Ocean's birthday
party oh nice Ocean's birthday party
they ran and they gave each other a hug
Hi how are you doing and then Brittany
has talked to Katie a couple times too
okay
um and Katie did just she bowed out of a
relationship just because stassi did
Katie oh really yeah oh that's
interesting
um there is such a demand for Mama's
beer cheese I know but it's just it's so
hard to do with food there's so many
laws and it's expensive yeah we know
it's very very expensive you know and
it's you know we we tried a couple
things we got the merch coming out we do
have a mama's beer cheese on the way
here I got I just finalized it but uh
we're gonna try and do something she
kills it in Kentucky like she sells out
before it's even in Kentucky but I just
to figure out how to do it in the
packaging the packaging and the way you
produce like you have there's certain
laws that you have to have certain parts
of the kitchen all that I would love to
I would love to it would but no hard
plans right now no hard plans and and
maybe we'll entertain it in the future I
mean I want to because this stuff is so
good and she like I said she makes it in
her kitchen every day she's in the
kitchen right now making it like she's
just pumping it out but she sells it to
everybody all the festivals yeah and she
does really well
when if and when will you let Crews
watch Vanderpump Rules I don't really
know if I'm gonna have a choice I mean
it's true he's already got more uh um
technical skills than I do smart on that
iPad so I'm sure he's gonna watch it one
of these days and I'm sure he's going to
have lots of questions and he's making
sure that's my douchebag dad and you
know it is what it is maybe he won't be
interested at all he'll be like yeah
sure my parents are on the show so
embarrassing I mean maybe not I don't
know I mean who knows we with our group
who knows do you love being a dad I love
it I love it more than I ever thought
and I just said this morning I'm like my
heart is I love being here we're back
and doing things again and having fun
and I miss it and all that but my heart
hurts because I miss my son so much I
love him so much he's like the best
thing in the entire world and I just I
just I miss him when he's next to me and
it makes me tear up yeah I just I love
him I didn't know he could love
something so much of course I love my
wife very much too but your son is just
like I just want to protect him and I'm
constantly on the phone with my
mother-in-law cause she's the only one
who watches them did he have his cookies
at two o'clock did he get his blanket
it's 3 15 did he did he take it out how
many times is he blinking like right you
know like I just I'm a helicopter dad
that's so funny helicopter father I'm
like I have to know what he's doing at
all time where he's at did he get his
hair cut is he eating did he brush his
teeth is he playing with this toy it's
three o'clock is he watching Miss Rachel
Miss Rachel's like Miss Rachel is a
queen Miss Rachel's a toaster she is
yeah I love her please tell her if you
ever talk to words I love her I will I
will she is literally like our other my
other wife no she's amazing just taught
crew so much to talk and I can't even
yeah do like she's magic she's magic
magic
we love her um I love that by the way I
feel like you could totally tell on
social media and it would have been
wouldn't have been something I think a
lot of people would have guessed about
you but like how you so fell into
fatherhood like head first I mean I
always knew I'd be a good dad but I
didn't know like I'm just I'm already
ready for the next one really yeah yeah
we have a couple things going on this
summer but I think the plan and this is
the plan is to start in August to start
trying quote unquote trying well it's
really it's a beautiful thing to watch
I'm really happy for you thank you um
okay a few more from the fans
um there's this conversation being had
on the Summer House reunion now
um where a lot of the girls are accusing
Lindsay of just being like kind of a
misery to work with treating production
like really rude and the crew did you
guys ever have issues like that where
anybody you know they got famous and
started to act and was rude and
condescending and difficult to work with
when it came to production we shut that
down right away I never ever ever
allowed anybody to be rude to production
because these people are the ones that
work their asses off they're there night
and day they don't get sleep and they
are the ones doing their job and if you
go off on them then you can get off the
set we don't allow that on our show now
that's when I was on I don't know what's
been going on last two years I know
production has changed a lot when I left
they got new show Runners and knew this
and knew that but you know
I did I get angry at him a couple times
yes of course but they know how to they
know how to work each and one of us they
know how to pull us aside on what to say
and how to cool us down and they're
really good at it but you know they're
all good people I'm still in contact
with pretty much all of them we talk all
the time especially a lot more now
because they're all kind of not want to
know what Bertie and I are going to do
of course um and they're all kind of
like what are they gonna do you know
especially Jeremiah who's the head show
running right now and he's kind of like
what's Jackson Britney going to do and
uh so everything's just being talked but
for the most part uh or for when I was
on the show no no we do not allow you to
talk negatively to producers show
Runners no this is their job you're
lucky to be where you are people would
give the right arm to be on television I
agree
um this was an interesting question did
Raquel ever try to make a move on you no
I never liked her it's not my type and
is there I don't like nothing she's a
beautiful woman yeah it's not my type
okay and I'm sure you've heard about the
rumor that she also like was [__]
around on Brock and Sheena I don't
believe you don't believe it I think
that was just I think I think rumors
were just flying around like crazy on
that and I normally I'd be like well
maybe but no no Brock and Sheena are
solid I love them by the way he's had
such like for me a 180 I think he's such
a good dad such a good dad he's so good
and he's like good at business and we
got a lot of things that him and I are
working on we're going to be doing a
tour pretty soon and uh he's been
working on it it's just he's such a
great great guy and he's a good father
he's a good man he's just so happy
doesn't really like to have any negative
you know around him wants to work out I
like is the guy's guy that's not like
that have you been to the sandwich shop
yet I have not do you want to get it I
am definitely going to go I texted
Ariana because I saw some sandwiches on
Tick Tock that I really like I'm like
can you please incorporate these into
your yeah lunch menu and she laughed so
yeah I'm definitely gonna go do you know
like the status of the opening I I'm
sure it's I mean they said it should be
right now right now so they said
beginning June end of May that's where
we are right so it should be right now
and I know from what I've heard they've
raised a lot of money did they do like I
want to say around 250k because
yeah off the merch because our friend
Janet who's been on the show many times
she does their merch she's in charge of
running it all
um and she said yeah they've made about
like 260. yeah they sat on the reunion
they had made like north of 200 000 yeah
so which is great I mean that's enough
to get the uh ball rolling for sure it
is not cheap to start a sandwich shop or
any kind of business especially on the
street that they're on I know Sunset
that's that's uh no they're right on on
Santa Monica Boulevard and Robertson
that's right by so sir is right here
Christian Louboutins over here I mean
you're by Max Fields yeah and then
you're going to have a sandwich shop so
the rent can't be cheap and so you got
to push a lot of sandwiches yep so I
don't I of course I wish the best for
them I hope it kills it and I hope it
puts shorts in the sandies out of
business crazy I hope it does really
well do you have a regret from any of
your time I regret the time I was
unfaithful to my wife my wife yeah I
forgot that's the one thing I would take
back yeah of course that's a good answer
I made a mistake you know and I regret
it till this day you know no
justification to what I did uh but I
worked my ass off to get my wife back
and she's you know is the most amazing
woman on the planet but like I said I
worked and worked and worked and worked
she didn't just say take me back no I
had to prove it took me to her family to
her family like
I had to do a lot of work but you know I
messed up I made a mistake on my own it
wasn't had nothing to do with with the
person or whatever I didn't like myself
at the time I was going through a diva
moment myself I just going through it I
was depressed I lost lost my dad there
was just a lot going on you know with my
life yeah not justifying at all but this
is just what you do when you start to
spiral out of control you just latch
onto anything and like I said it had
nothing to do with the other person or
who it was like I would have you know
hooked up with a hole in the wall if it
was there it looked at me right away it
had nothing to do with that it just I
hated who I was and I loved that my wife
came to me and she's like listen I mean
she kind of knew she saw to me that I I
that I wasn't doing this maliciously she
saw it and I was so hurt and I was going
through depression like I was locking
myself in my man cave and just not
coming out like I was just doing
everything in my power just to hurt
myself because I just did not like who I
was as a human being and you know she
introduced me to
I was going to do some other hard things
to myself to be honest with you and I
was just like I was going to lock myself
in a room and I don't know what I was
going to do but then she introduced me
to we cannabis at the time this was
years ago and thank God for that that
saved my marriage and saved my I don't
have to take pills to you know be
anxiety
um but yeah it really helped I mean she
stuck by me and she rode with me through
all the ups and downs and she was there
and she's just an amazing person I will
say having been at your wedding which
was so beautiful it really was you know
you see someone's whole relationship
play out on TV but to like be in the
presence it was so it really was so
beautiful and you guys really
um you had come such a long way and you
still are really just headed in the
right direction right and it was so
beautiful and it like really everyone's
like what was the wedding like I'm like
it was like full of love it was really
it was a lot you know it I wanted to be
bigger and better there just because we
came so far from where we were and I
wanted to just celebrate the fact that
we are and honor that and show her
family how much I care I love her and I
wanted her to have everything that she
wanted for this wedding there was
nothing that I said no to right so it
was whatever she wanted she got and it
was the wedding of her dreams did it
cost a lot of money absolutely much
um I think we paid we got a lot for for
free of course because it was televised
they still paid about a buck 60. okay
which is a lot by the way it looked like
a more expensive wedding it looked like
a half a million dollars a lot of like
we didn't like I think like the cakes we
got yeah flowers stuff like that because
people wanted to be on the show I think
I had to pay for like the whole I paid
for everybody's hotel room because I
want everyone to stay in the castle that
was in the wedding party
um things like that was expensive that's
what kind of drove it up but um I mean
we had like wagyu steaks we had I mean I
had Hooters come in for free yeah that
was the best part you know I just feel I
wanted to be fun and yes and I wanted to
keep a little Kentucky a little Southern
girl you know a little country girl we
wanted to eat wings and tacos at night
and we just wanted to have fun we didn't
want to make it too you know serious
serious we want everyone just to have a
good time I will say having you back in
the Bravo Universe I watched you as I
watched Robin's live it's so great it
and I'm so happy that you guys are doing
so well and I really hope you come back
to the show in whatever format you guys
are comfortable with I'm so glad you
came on the toast thank you so much for
being so honest oh thank you so much for
having me and make sure to keep up with
Jackson Britney on social I know you're
on Cameo our podcast when reality hits
are you loving being a podcaster I love
it and you know my favorite part is
doing the commercials oh well of course
because I love making money I know but I
just love doing it
yeah on Bravo you were getting cut all
the time like just for time and watch
Evans live they cut so much for time but
you could go on for you're literally the
chattiest person I know I can talk a lot
and I literally I get I say so much
stuff that I'm probably not supposed to
say that I have to have my manager
listen to it and then my public system
then it goes to fire smart so I'm
because I see a lot of things on there
like nope nope nope nope that's so funny
well one reality hits It's a podcast one
podcast you can listen to it yes
Jax thank you so much for replacing Jax
today it's been a pleasure oh by the way
I just want to say congratulations to
Brittany and her cup sheet it launched
today it's really cute out really check
that out everybody it's I'll do a better
job it's cover-ups it's bathing suits at
one pieces and two pieces and by the way
for the big breasted ladies I tried it
on yesterday and it fit me splendidly
like it's a really very supportive cup
she's such a good brand they always make
like good big boob bathing suits and
Britney's are really cute so congrats
Brittany I wish Britney was here I love
you Jax thank you I love you too I hope
you guys enjoyed the episode have a
great weekend we'll see you on Monday
bye